[Musique]
elisabeth vallet bonsoir bonsoir ça
faisait un petit bout oui vous avez bien
ça va bien merci froidement oui je
baisse assez générale il fait il fait
peu moins trois moscou fait moins 30 ici
raphaël jacob bonsoir
j'ai fait longuement je trouvais
important aujourd'hui de faire le point
sur la crise ukrainienne avec tamara
l'aller le contexte historique que
remonter la chute de l'urss et cetera
l'otan on l'a beaucoup fait du point de
vue de poutine est tentant de le faire à
linverse du point de vue du président
américain de washington je commence avec
vous il y la bête
que peut faire washington de 20,7 cette
volonté ferme de poutine de reconstruire
un mur de sécurité autour de lui tout à
fait laisser vraiment on voit vraiment
la volonté poutine depuis depuis
quelques années déjà depuis le sommet de
bucarest peut-être cette volonté de
sécuriser un peu sa frontière en
utilisant certains arguments ou
certaines postures qui sommes pour le
moins surprenante c'est un enjeu
déterminant pour le prix jean bart
hayden aujourd'hui parce que l'on est en
train de remettre ont pu potentiellement
remettre en cause la pax americana c'est
à dire cet ordre international libéral
qui est en orbite autour de washington
depuis 1945 et le président biden n'a
pas d'autre option que d'être ferme et
de définir clairement les objectifs et
et de de transiger le cas échéant avec
avec le président poutine mais ne ne pas
donner l'impression qu'il hésite or on
le sait sa bourde en quelque sorte où il
a dit que finalement peut-être qu'une
petite incursion de l'autre côté de la
frontière n'était pas une invasion c'est
un problème on a vu blinken tout de
suite donc son secrétaire d'état dire
non non ce n'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe le problème de bail donne c'est
que sa légitimité à l'intérieur du pays
et éroder sur le plan international on
parle de la débâcle afghane et depuis
lors et c'est certain que son orgueil de
deal a été un peu un peu érodés et les
républicains lui demandait de prendre
des sanctions de même que la gauche du
parti démocrate
il ne l'a pas fait pensant qu'il pouvait
transiger avec poutine de toute évidence
ça n'est pas ce qui se passe il y a
vraiment une escalade qui est en train
de se dérouler aux portes de l'europe
donc il va falloir qu'ils agissent
pourquoi parce que téhéran et pékin sont
dans les estrades et regarde ce qui se
passe et si jamais des données fiables
sur ce dossier là eh bien ça serait
peut-être à tout un tout un contrôle
total des crises à l'international qui
pourrait lui échapper je vais revenir
tout à l'heure sur la question de la
petite ou la grande invasion quand il
s'est échappé parce qu'effectivement ce
que vous avez dit beaucoup de gens
n'osent en même temps c'est révélateur
d'une scission en europe parce qu'il ya
des pays européens qui disait à
washington en coulisse écouter ci ne
fait qu'ajouter un peu d'un petit
morceau va pas nous tous viré à l'envers
pour chômer fermons la parenthèse façon
générale à raphaël qu'est ce qui t'a en
juin pour washington pour ou commencer
en fait je me permettrai patrice malgré
ces ovnis dit avec tout le respect de
tête rouvrir cette parenthèse port est
les clés d'une perspective justement
américaine parce que ce qu'elle me suis
plainte contre le secrétaire d'état
américain essaie de répéter depuis des
jours tout au long de la semaine pendant
son voyage en europe c'était qu'il y
allait avoir une réponse forte et unie
ce monsieur poutine devait aller de
l'avant à quel point ce que l'occident
est vraiment unis vous mentionniez
l'europe il faut en parler savait il y
avait un certain république en natation
américaine il ya quelques jours mais
promener pour pas le nommer ancien
candidat présidentiel qui se moquent
instruits dans le sien en disant je le
cite là c'est une station service qui
fait 100 mètres un pays mais je vous
soumettrai que dans un contexte où le
baril de pétrole est en fait cet exil
vers les 100 dollars et que c'est à peu
près le tiers d'approvisionnement en
pétrole en europe qui viennent la russie
dans les pays voisins comme la pologne
l'estonie c'est plus de 60% monsieur
poutine tient présentement beaucoup de
gens en europe par n'étaient pas
l'expression par les bijoux de famille
donc c'est très difficile pour le
président américain de réellement
présenter un front uni face à moscou
présente donc cessez gracq dans le temps
c'est une modulation elisabeth tous les
pays ne voudrais pas réagir de la même
façon en europe bon raphaël par du
pétrole du gaz ou s'ils quittent
l'europe importe beaucoup de gaz de la
russie
comme si l'otan ou six allers se
redéfinir absolument et les fractures
sont importantes à l'intérieur même de
l'europe selon que vous êtes un état
balte que vous êtes l'allemagne vous
n'avez pas du tout la même vision du
danger que représente la russie les
états baltes sont aujourd'hui équipés
par les états unis ont d'ailleurs obtenu
l'autorisation de transférer une partie
de cet armement vers kiev eux ont
l'impression d'être sur la ligne de
front et ça fait longtemps qu'il sent
juste pour qu'on soit clair pour les
jeunes parce que c'est tout petit mais
c'est l'estonie la lituanie convoi en
rollat les trois petits bleus connaît un
collet qui étaient des républiques
soviétiques et autres qui avaient été
annexées autrefois qui dans lesquels la
population russe à l'instar de ce convoi
dans l'est de l'ukraine est assez
importante aussi donc c'est intéressant
dans les similitudes qui fait que
ressentent cette pression là et puis de
même que par exemple des états comme la
finlande auquel il ya des
positionnements différents puis si on
regarde effectivement du côté de
l'allemagne bayeux voix poutine avec la
main sur le robinet du gaz et ça ça les
inquiète vraiment de manière importante
dans le même temps la france macron
étant est en élection et lui s'est
présenté comme le président européiste
il est à la tête aujourd'hui de l'union
européenne il faut qu'il arrive à
fédérer les européens autour d'une d'une
sensibilité commune d'une posture
commune et c'est vraiment un problème
donc oui l'otan est en train de se
redéfinir mais ce qu'il faut le
peut-être noter c'est que quoi que dise
poutine le temps avait ouvert la porte à
la russie à l'époque de la chute du mur
de berlin donc l'otan n'a pas toujours
été opposée à la russie il était qu'il
soit impérialiste culturellement et est
un autre problème mais il n'y a jamais
eu il n'a pas toujours eu ces
dissensions là et puis l'ukraine était
neutre en 2014 lorsqu'il s'est avancé en
crimée donc là aussi l'exigence notre
alité de l'ukraine il trace les lignes
rouges que l'on veut et enfin peut-être
l'élément le plus important il faut se
souvenir qu'en 94 lorsque l'ukraine rend
ces armes nucléaires à la russie la
garantie c'est que la russie
n'interviendra pas donc la mémoire est
une faculté sélectif bon justement
revenons à l'ukraine
si vladimir poutine décide de faire un
coup d'éclat d'envahir une partie la
crimée et déjà aller la rechercher sont
hélas pas recherché car on voit rien
expliquer ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
le rapidement le l'ukraine une fois que
le gouvernement pro russe a été chassé
les ressources du bon vin peut bien
faire ça mais nous pas question de
laisser aller la crimée le port de
sébastopol donc on garde la crimée est
là juridiquement c'est encore en ukraine
mais de facto les russes ont le contrôle
de la crimée
raphaël sillage il est ce que ça mais
pas poutine baden dans l'obligation de
répondre quand même pas juste d'envoyer
des armes mais répondent comme un
message commun d'esker qui que ce soit
moindrement sain d'esprit aux états unis
qui souhaitent présentement un conflit
armé avec la russie c'est ce qu'on est
en train de voir qui dans les derniers
jours à washington notamment au congrès
c'est la possibilité plan on se projette
on n'est pas là il ya personne qui soit
qu'on se rende l'âme et on y pense quand
même de financer directement par le
biais notamment du trésor public
américain une insurrection une
éventuelle insurrection ukrainienne anti
russe si monsieur poutine doivent aller
de l'avant donc ça c'est une option qui
semble considérer au dos de sa beauté on
brandit le spectre de sanctions depuis
des jours pour produire des semaines en
métal des sanctions on en a imposé
combien et il faut toujours revoir je
crois cette affaire le tout cette
dynamique la partie kama de la
perspective de moscou parce que d'un
côté vous avez la menace de sanctions
comme encore une fois on en impose
depuis des années on le fait sous le
vent l'administration obama
c'est une station de chambre ça semble
avoir donné franchement pas grand chose
la perspective de la dîme poutine de son
régime
l'expansion de la tente sakho arrière
parce que c'est comme ça qu'ils voient
l'ukraine depuis longtemps c'est vu
comme une menace fondamentale à la
survie même du régime donc qu'est ce que
vous pensez qu'ils pèsent le plus dans
la balance pour moscou la menace de
sanctions additionnelles contre et des
oligarques russes ou une menace
fondamentale à la survie du régime
évidemment poser la question c revient y
répondre pour répondre à votre question
patrice qu'est-ce que peut vraiment
faire joe biden en guise de réponse
franchement je suis pas sûr qu'ils en
deviennent très très bonnes réponses
actuellement bon il trop vieille à petit
les éléments que l'idée de menace
fondamentale à la survie du régime c'est
avant tout il ya une forme de populisme
ou poutine surf sur le nationalisme
russe parce que ça va pas très bien fait
c'est plus sa survie de poutine que la
survie du régime peut-être qui est en
jeu d'une part d'autre part les
sanctions ce qui a changé
fondamentalement
et c'est vraiment important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le premier partenaire de
la russie c'est la chine et que des
sanctions qui affecterait la russie
toucherait deux partenaires l'europe qui
a pas intérêt à ce qu on ferme le
robinet du gaz et la chine qui a
vraiment qui transigent de manière très
importante avec la russie poutine etchi
se rencontrent en février prochain le
mois prochain lors des jeux olympiques
il est tout à fait possible qu'il
continue ils ont déjà un certain nombre
de mécanismes financiers parallèles pour
arriver à contourner donc les le
magnétisme occidental qui est sont déjà
mises en place on peut tout à fait
imaginer que cela mène à une alliance de
circonstance il faut pas se leurrer mais
une alliance importante entre deux
ennemis combat ou deux adversaires pas
une mais deux adversaires importants du
régime de ben ali donne ça ça sera
changerait substantiellement la donne et
c'est pour ça qu'il va falloir qu'ils
trouvent un moyen d'agir de façon ou
d'une autre ok dernier point sur
l'ukraine après je vais vous entendre
sur byden et la politique intérieure
quand même dernier point sur baidu quand
les russes disent car on a réunifié
l'allemagne 90
il ya eu on en a parlé un peu plus tôt
avec les tamarins il ya eu ces
pourparlers importants américain russes
et là on a dit
ok on aurait promis que l'ukraine par
exemple a fait les pays de du pacte de
varsovie l'otan n'irait pas les chercher
la pop up provoqué éclate manque donc
qui sera libre de faire partie de l'otan
en fait
est-ce que cette promesse là c'est clair
pour tout le monde pour les historiens
elisabeth que effectivement on s'est
engagé le washington s'est engagé à ne
pas inclure des pays comme l'ukraine
alors la légende veut que ce soit une
boulette de james baker 1 ces postes est
pas une promesse c'est un lien
personnages importants de
l'administration et ça a été démenti
tout de suite semblerait-il mais même à
ça quand on regarde du côté des
historiens même gorbatchev lui-même
d'ibm ce n'était pas si évident
financière n'était pas si clair tard le
soir oui c'est ça et quelques verres de
vodka vrai parfois il ya des choses qui
sont eux qui sont discutées de manière
étrange mais toujours est il qu il ya eu
un certain nombre de transactions qui
ont fait été fait à ce moment là c'est
certain que le modèle otanesque et
démocratique l'ordre libéral a été une
espèce de bulldozer qui est passé sur
l'europe de l'est et qui parfois écrasé
certains acquis importants qui s'était
exercé de l'autre côté du mur mais mais
la porte était ouverte sur la rue si la
philosophie était moins ce que poutine
raconte aujourd'hui on réécrit un peu
l'histoire mais six tout le monde et 20
secondes avant qu'on parle de patte de
politique intérieure parce qu'on ne
parlait beaucoup de la crimée l'on parle
de l'ukraine ont parlé des années 90 un
épisode je pense qu'on en oublie qui est
entre tout seul c'est à dire la géorgie
en 2008 et ce qui s'est passé en 2008 il
avait déjà fait parler de james baker
l'ancien secrétaire d'état ancien ami
proche et demande la famille bush cette
président bush est en fonction en 2002
s'adonner à la maison blanche et il
était allé flotter faire flotter en
public au sommet de bucarest
au printemps 2008 l'idée que l'otan
ajoute la georgie et les quatre mois
plus tard frictionne envahissait la
georges est exact contre l'avis des
services de renseignement se faire
l'intéressant américain examinera des
rockets alors il reste les états unis la
politique intérieure l'oeil il n'y a
plus rien qui passe raphaël france avec
vous
comment commence en ligne les prochains
mois pour joe biden mal an pendant un
mois en un mot tu es c'est que
présentement les ce qui lui fait le plus
mal politiquement ce sont évidemment les
questions de nature économique c'est pas
évident pour moi ce stade si ce qui peut
vraiment faire ce qui est vraiment de
son ressort à lui et son administration
particulière pour ce qui est la lutte à
l'inflation était vous regardez le
sondage de cbs qui était publié dimanche
dernier on demande aux américains qu'est
ce qui pourra changer votre appréciation
du président parce que c'est par exemple
qui sont en mesure de faire passer
certains de ces plaques sont bloqués
comme son énorme plan de réforme sociale
c'est moins du quart qui répondent oui
parce que quand on leur demande si il
était capable de table et l'inflation de
faire baisser l'inflation est ce que ça
pourrait améliorer votre opinion plus
60% 18 son plus gros problème
présentement il est là ce qu'il y a des
problèmes sur lesquels il a l'air de ne
pas être suffisamment concentré et même
s'il s'y mettaient à temps plein à
partir de maintenant c'est pas clair
pour moi que nécessairement énormément
de pouvoir sur ces derniers présentement
il y aura des hausses du taux d'intérêt
là bas mais je sais c'est pas magique
non plus la bête et et la hausse des
taux d'intérêt va avoir un impact sur le
portefeuille des individus ça va aussi
avoir un impact sur sur le mode de vie
sur les hypothèques et cetera donc de
toute manière c'est un peu une situation
on a l'impression qu'il va perdre sur
sur tous les plans d'autant que
l'éléphant dans la pièce s'est
littéralement le parti républicain qui
colle qui persistent qu'à changer
profondément assez vraiment l'élément
important que l'on commençait à voir aux
dernières élections quand on discuter
tous ensemble mais là le changement est
ancrée il et ça n'est plus le même parti
et ce parti-là ne veut plus n'est plus
un parti qui est enclin à promouvoir la
démocratie qui est enclin à transiger
alors encore une fois rien de dit il n'y
a pas de calais dire vous voulez là je
suis
mais non mais non milliards de dire donc
finalement qui était qui était un credo
tram pesc et qu'abidal s'est approprié
on le voit il est pas meilleur
négociateur en fait là où train de
passer en force la baille donne
d'ailleurs on voit un changement de
style ils essayent peut-être d'avoir
d'être un peu plus populiste on commence
à l'entendre dire que ça prend peut-être
un peu plus listes à gauche pour gagner
contre le populisme de droite oui
aujourd'hui qu'il ya inauguré d'ailleurs
cette usine de puces il y avait des
élans
elle 35 ans c'est comme ça trente
secondes sur sur la fin des comment
comment résumer y at il une voie pour
s'en sortir y at il un
sujet qui vole le banc mais non c'était
aulas la baie on a fait un bon tour
d'horizon je suis très content de la
crise guinéenne avec vous avec tamara 20
avec notre journal et sur le terrain
merci d'avoir été là on se retrouve pour
d'autres panels américain bientôt bonne
fin de semaine
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit